the Trump administration is expected to
unveil news sanctions against Russia
today they would be the administration's
third round of sanctions against Russia
in about a month they are expected to
target Russian companies that supplied
equipment to Syria and helped the regime
allegedly used chemical weapons this
follows weekend missile strikes by us
British and French forces on what the
Pentagon says with three chemical
weapons facilities Seth Doane is the
only network correspondent inside Syria
this morning he visited the town of duma
which was hit by the suspected Syrian
government chemical attack good morning
from duma the biggest city in eastern
goota and a hard-fought battle for
Syrian forces we have been invited here
today brought in by the Syrian
government to show that they are in
control of this place this was a very
important significant battle for Syrian
forces because this is the biggest town
in a suburb of Damascus and controlling
this place means controlling more of the
capital city for President Bashar
al-assad and his forces just looking
around you can see what a hard battle
this was completely destroyed buildings
buildings where you're missing entire
walls you can see cars that have been on
fire you can see the effects of where
artillery shells had hit unbelievably
we're also seeing many civilians who
have stayed here and are trying to pick
up the pieces president bashar al-assad
and his forces since that missile strike
by coalition forces have gone out of
their way apparently to show that they
are still in control of course the
russians were vital in as an ally in
this battle and we saw images from over
the weekend of assad meeting with
lawmakers already starting to look
forward to rebuilding his country saying
four hundred billion dollars would be
needed to rebuild Syria's economy for
CBS this morning
I'm Seth Doane in Douma